thank you guys for coming to this
session this is debugging diversity my
name is n1 Simmons and I'm really happy
to be here at strange loop and I want to
start with a story several years ago an
actor own a television show faced a
dilemma he was the start of a TV show
that wasn't doing all that well in the
ratings but that wasn't the problem this
actor learned that an actress who also
starred on the show was not being paid
as much as the other male actors now
this actor was beloved by the fans and
that gave him a lot of influence so he
went to the studio executives and used
his influence to demand equal pay for
this actress and he was successful the
actress received pay equal to her male
peers the television show was Star Trek
the actor was littered Nimoy who of
course played Spock and the actress was
Nichelle Nichols who played oh ha that's
right literate neem oil was that with
equal pay for equal work way before it
was cool Nimoy used his influence to fix
a defect in the TV industry he debunked
pay for Nichelle Nichols and by fixing
this bug he further her position as an
actress which gave her access to better
pay now you may be wondering what does
this have to do with the conference like
strange loop well you may have heard
that the software development industry
is not all that diverse and that we
suffer from a lack of diversity where
there's open source or a close source
developing code or the pouring cold the
people working in software development
do not reflect the general population
and rewards like pay promotions and
positions of leadership are often not
equally distributed we face the reality
that a woman working today in software
development who is master tools like
github Ruby and SQL has less access to
equal pay than an actress on a filled TV
show from the 90
60s however I believe that literate
Nimoy provided a model for how we can
address this problem notice that Nimoy
did not wait for Paramount to rule out a
better pay program nor did he wait for
his superiors to create a better salary
policy Nimoy acted based on his sense of
fairness Nimoy lent nickels his
privilege his privilege as a male actor
and he helped her participate and the
financial benefits of his junior
privilege and I think that there are a
lot of literate Nimoy out here and I
think that there are other ways to debug
the diversity and inclusion challenges
in software development now one key
thing that we have to understand before
we get into debugging diversity is
understanding the difference between
diversity and inclusion and there is a
difference so imagine that you're
throwing a party diversity is sending
invitations to your guests that's easy
to do you pop them in the mail you're
done however inclusion goes further than
diversity inclusion means not just
inviting people to your party is making
sure that they feel welcome and
comfortable at your party you understand
that some of your guests had to make a
longer journey to get to your house and
so you're a little bit more welcoming
when they arrive you may also realize
that some of your guests have food
allergies so you have different meal
options for those guests or some of your
friends might not drink alcohol so you
have non-alcoholic options for those
guests so that's an inclusion inclusion
requires empathy and that means that you
take the time to understand that people
are different diversity is easy to game
and we see a lot of big companies doing
that they release these big numbers and
they really say well we're doing what we
can but the numbers never change year
after year we see companies like Google
and Facebook fell to really make change
I think that the work is important i
think that shooting for a more inclusive
technology industry will pay better
dividends you know literate nimoy saw
that a big company like paramount could
not solve the problem and i think that
it will take a grassroots movement of
everyone in this room everyone in
technology to really affect change by
acting on our sense of fairness now we
work in tech right and we had the
benefit of understanding how grassroots
movements work open source software was
a grassroots movement in software
development and one of the first books
on open source software is a book called
the cathedral and the bazaar by eric s
raymond and this book starts with
raymond exploring the miracle of linux
most of us use Linux every day we don't
really think much about it but when it
was first being written it was just
miracle it was this complicated kernel
that you let everyone contribute to and
the hope was that you would create a
useful operating system and it worked
there are you know many linux
distributions today so Raymond and his
book analyzed the principles open source
software that he saw in Linux
development and applied it to his own
work he had two models there was the
cathedral was just a centralized very
buttoned down tighten down development
model that you see in close source
development and he contrasted that to
this bizarre this open source model that
was this babbling boisterous area where
it was loud and power was distributed
but it worked and not only did it work
by the bizarre model featured better
outcomes than the cathedral model now
one of the most famous it's closer in
this book is this given enough eyeballs
all bugs are shallow and I hope that
some of you have heard about that phrase
if you haven't read the book it's a
really quick read but I like the more
formal version of this also in the book
and that's this given a large enough
beta tester and co-developer base almost
every problem
can be characterized quickly and the
figs obvious to someone that is a
statement of inclusion Raymond linked
the size of the co-developer base which
is kind of an old term but the size of
people contributing the open-source
software to innovation and the ability
to solve problems which is the heart of
innovation so if we let suffer
development be this big boisterous
bazaar where everyone's welcome to comic
contribute then I really think that
there's no problem that we can solve but
well that's the promise of inclusion
that we can have a total industry where
we have the power to solve any problem
the sad reality is that just like our
repositories are protected by
permissions and passwords often our
companies are protected by privilege and
there are voices that we keep out of
this bizarre because we don't create a
space for them to take part in our
projects and in our companies and there
are certain groups they have a hard time
lending their voices to the babbling
bizarre that Raymond described because
they lack privilege and you know this is
really tragic because whatever problem
you have either in your source code or
having you ship software there's someone
out there who knows how to fix it but
often these people are denied entry into
our companies but I think that if you
taken the time to learn the skills
necessary to develop software you'd be
surprised how you you already know maybe
even intuitively how you can debug
diversity technology and I want to go
through how we can use those techniques
in in in this efforts now they don't the
debugging techniques that I hope
everyone is familiar with are expected
behavior tracing refactoring and sample
code and let's look at the one at a time
so I work with the team of about 15
software developers I'm a program
manager and I make sure that we have the
project's laid out and that the team
knows what they're working on what's
important
ultimately that we ship software to our
customers and we work very closely with
our QA team and where you always have to
remember that the first step in
understanding a bug is what's the
expected behavior you know what should
the future do and likewise the first
debugging technique that we can apply to
fixing the inclusion problems of
technology is the principle of expected
behavior we can't understand the
problems caused by lack of inclusion in
tech without understanding well what's
the expected behavior in technology
environments what should people do in
tech spaces now I have male privilege
and whether it's a workplace or our tech
conference like this one or a happy hour
people who have male privilege in tech
we benefit from this pattern but we
often fail to see how people who don't
have male privilege are denied those
benefits of a friend named Catherine out
I follow her on Twitter so we're kind of
best friends I captain found it a very
popular website called the muse and you
know she's a successful starter founder
and she shared experience that she
allowed me to to repeat and I've heard
this for many women who work in
technology and this happens on a regular
basis so she goes to a happy hour for
founders and she walks into the room and
people are having drinks and obviously
there's usually a lot of men who are in
the room and she might be the only woman
who's in the room is so you know she
walks up and more often than not
Catherine a founder in her own right
we'll have someone turned to her and say
oh whose girlfriend are you right so she
did not get the benefit of the doubt
that those who have male privilege
experience and women and people of color
and LGBT people often are exposed on an
almost daily basis the behavior that
those of us who have gender privilege
would never expect so the ability to see
these lapses and behavior that's vital
to helping everyone understand that we
should stop pre
judging people only because they defy
the patrons that were used to seeing in
tech and those predators are based on
gender and race and sexual preferences
you know regardless everyone should be
given the basic respect of possibility
that this person is possibly as capable
as I am in technology so that's that's
that debugging technique we should keep
our eyes open for what should we expect
what levels of respect should we expect
to give to everyone regardless of what
they look like now the second technique
is tracing and you know often when
you're running code is hard to really
know the output so we often trace me
turn tracing on we might put the output
to a file or to a log and just like you
can trace code to find the small defects
in it you can turn on your inclusion
tracers and see the often subtle ways
that marginalized groups are excluded
from information and often is supposed
to microaggressions by the dominant
demographic in tech it's just Erica
Baker she works for slack now and she's
been a very visible advocate for trying
to fix the diversity problems in
technology and she shared her experience
of you know being the only black person
on the team and having a white coworker
make ridiculous assumptions about her
you know she would he would say well is
your boyfriend beating you she come from
a single-parent household and this
person seemed to be so fast in it with
her fictitious history of abuse and
neglect but he didn't mean he didn't get
to know her and often on other teams
that she worked at she would have to go
to beer taverns and she didn't really
drink beer but to fit in she had to
learn classic rock songs which if you
like classic rock that's great for you I
guess but you know she felt like she had
to lose her identity to be able to fit
in to check and you know this is not
unusual often people of color in tech we
have to lose our lives to make a living
we have to hide our identities to fit
into technology but if someone had their
inclusion tracers on they could
spotted this for example we shouldn't
assume that everyone wants to drink
alcohol even though this a alcohol
culture technology we should be
sensitive to people who don't drink
alcohol and everyone here can kind of
walk through the cultural code of your
workplace and think about is anyone
being hurt by our culture are there
things that happen that if we simply
paid attention we would see that you
know what we're making this environment
uncomfortable for certain groups all
right so let's turn to the inclusion
principle of refactoring and we all know
what we factoring is you want to change
the internal structure of the code maybe
make it easier to read or easier to
maintain and you know we all kind of
want to fall into the allure of new
features but I really believe that you
make legacy code easier to maintain by
refactoring and so how do we refactor
our culture's in technology how do we do
inclusion refactoring so that we can
make the technology industry a more
inclusive one how do we change the
internal structure of how
under-represented groups are viewed in
tech so let me give you an example of
how we can refactor inclusion a few
years ago a famous tech founder gave an
example of how he interviews people for
for working because he worked at a big
company its stocking you may have heard
of this but it's called the airport test
right and that's the idea that when he
interviewed candidates he would make a
decision on what I want to be stuck in
an airport with this candidate and so
you know that's kind of weird because
one this person who was a white male
probably doesn't fly with a lot of black
men or black women and so you're already
kind of selecting out certain people
from this airport test and this is
really a terrible way to hire people if
you want a diverse workplace for example
how does a hiring managers personal
taste determine if someone is a fit
right that shouldn't be an issue at all
just because you like sitting an air
or it in maybe you're in the pokemon or
maybe you're into whatever your cultural
expectations have no relevance or how
successful that person can can be and if
your culture is most of the white males
then guess what groups usually fell the
airport test and so I think we can
refactor the airport test and instead of
looking for who would I want to be stuck
at an airport with let's look at who
would be really an amazing person on my
team let's look at how we do our job
description so look at how we ask okay
this is the work that we want this
person to do and totally wrap the
selection process around that we
probably won't ask well how have you
solved problems at other workplaces that
you've worked at how have you reduce the
amount of bugs that are reported after
release those are the types of questions
that we should use when interviewing
candidates so let's refactor the airport
tests let's make it into the rock star
test how can we create rock stars at our
companies who are really contribute to
what we do and that by doing that by
creating this rock star test we take the
eye out of the selection process that
the airport test really makes you you
have to think about and we replaced it
with the needs of your company so let's
stop trying to hire these cultural fits
let's hire people who can really be rock
stars at our companies so the next
diversity debugging technique that I
want to talk about is is sample code and
one way to debug code is to simply see
at a sample of similar to it that runs
well and in many ways another programmer
linds you code to help you make your
code better and of course this could be
a production code our code you have
running in a local branch now just like
you can Lin code to another person you
can lend privilege to someone else and
by doing that you can help
underrepresented groups get access to
information and events that naturally
flow to the dominant demographic
and most technology companies so men are
technology companies you can help women
know about that basketball game that
everyone plays thursdays after work that
the women just don't know about just let
them know just lend the privilege that
you have as a man in this bonding event
or you can when you're in a group of men
talking about tech and there's a woman
there you can say you know what i want
to know what susan has to say about this
because often when we have conversations
we don't give women the benefit of the
doubt of being competent and there are
times where I've seen the woman who
wrote the code standing there and
they're talking about the code and she's
not even in the conversation and I lit
privilege a few years ago I spoke in a
South by Southwest Interactive that
circumference in austin texas several
times and i was putting together a
proposal for south by and it was a dual
idea a dual panel where two people would
present and you know one key thing about
getting a panel successfully accepted
into South by is having a great
co-presenter and you know there were a
lot of a blog there were a lot of white
men who I could have went to but you
know what I said you know what I have
this this young lady who I work with on
a program at accompanying and she does
designing so my proposal was a design
related panel and sauce I could know
what I have male privilege I spoke at
that stuff by before I could probably
find a couple of white guys to present
with me who have a lot of visibility but
let me lend privilege to to her and see
what happens and so we talked about it
and we worked on their proposal together
we got accepted and so Anna Karen that's
her name was able to go to South by
Southwest and speak and then she the
next year after that she proposed her
own panel and that got accepted and now
she's involved in startups and doing
work and it's really a great benefit to
be able to be a woman she's from Mexico
to go into an investor's conference and
say you know what I just spoke ass off
myself
limitary about my company so so what can
we do with these debugging principles
well before I go into that I want to
talk about common this is common who's a
rapper and I spoke at github universe a
few days ago actually replica min here
and common was the person who performed
at a benefit for black girls code that
the conference had and it was a great
concert there's everyone no common you
know the rapper there might be my black
privilege talking that I know who common
is he's an amazing performer and while
coming has a lot of hits one of this
songs that I like the best is called
glory and it's from a movie called Selma
that's about the civil rights movement
and one of the lines from glory is this
one and it goes one day when the glory
comes it'll be ours it'll be ours and I
I like this song because it really
captures the essence of why I think that
diversity inclusion is so important to
do in technology because when we make
technology a more diverse and inclusive
industry that doesn't mean that white
women win or black women win or black
men win our LGBTQ a people win it means
that we all win because in every
movement in our nation's history to
advance the rights of the
disenfranchised we've seen this a few
weeks ago a brave Muslim American father
famously offered to lend someone the
copy of his Constitution and you
probably heard about this and in
response to this the ACLU offered anyone
who wanted a copy a copy so i got my
copy a few days ago and so you know
reading through the constitution which i
haven't read since probably
eighth grade and I'm thinking you know
what this this really holds up well and
I didn't realize that the founders of
the Constitution put a pull request
system into it and the idea is that you
could take changes have them reviewed
and then deploy to production these are
amendments and it's a really rough messy
process and that's what there's only
been 27 of them in 200 years but you
know just like in software development
version 1 it's pretty cool but really
the pull request so we're a lot of the
meat lies and so when I looked at the
amendments I saw a pattern for example
the 13th amendment to the Constitution
is famously known as the one that ended
slavery but when you read the Thirteenth
Amendment it doesn't say that you can't
enslave black people it said you can't
enslave anyone and so as the descendant
of black slaves I'm sure my ancestors
rejoiced at that amendment but really
all Americans should have rejoiced
because they now lived in a country
where everyone was surely free and when
the 17th amendment gave women the right
to vote I'm sure half the population was
happy that they were let into the
franchise but really all Americans
should have rejoiced because we live in
a nation where your gender was no longer
held against you at the ballot box and
when the Supreme Court fairly recently
the script declared that same-sex
marriage is marriage and there first
should be protected I'm sure a lot of
gay and lesbian couples rejoice but
really we all won because we now live in
a country where there were no limits
placed in love so as a nation we try to
form a more perfect union by dressing
the wrongs done the underrepresented
groups like people of color and women
and LGBT people but I really think that
we can form a more perfect software
industry by addressing our own peculiar
problems when we build software as a
place where everyone is welcome no
matter what you
like or who you love then we'll all win
because will work in an industry that
puts no limits on talent one day when
the glory comes it'll be ours it'll be
ours now I want to go into a few
takeaways that we can use to hopefully
put this into into action and I want to
talk about awareness action and then
being an ally so awareness is something
that I think a lot of you are already
doing because you're here you came to
the bug and diversity topic at strange
loop so I'm probably preaching to the
choir but I think we should put our
awareness into action i said like i said
i try to lend my privilege as a male in
tech by helping those who don't have no
privilege and you know after if you meet
me at a conference and you present as a
woman i'm probably going to say hey have
you ever thought about speaking at tech
conferences because i know how hard it
is to get here I know how hard it is to
stand behind this podium and some of you
may know me you know I probably said you
should speak at conferences and I
probably encourage you to to do that and
so that's what I try to do by being
aware of the disparities in our industry
I really tried to see what i can do to
lend my privilege to others a few months
ago actually last year I went to a
conference called craft in Budapest and
there was this woman that I met who
creates who has a startup that helped
students in foreign countries for about
their resumes for english-speaking
prefer english-speaking hiring managers
and I encouraged her to speak at craft
next year because I think she has a
great voice and so that's how I try to
have my awareness turned on and I also
encourage action I know that whenever I
give this talk people ask well what what
can I do to to act and not only that
most people say well you know there are
times where I want to debug diversity
but there are certain groups that say
you know what I'm good I don't need the
help and my response is that this is not
a silver bullet just like debugging code
it's not one way that you can always fix
every bug there's not one way that you
can always fix diversity and inclusion
in tech and a large part of what I try
to do as a person who acts in technology
to try to make it more inclusive is to
really just listen I try to listen to
under-represented groups and hear what
my fellow women in tech are going
through what LGBT QA people are going to
and then after you listen and spend time
trying to understand their experience
and their journey in tech you can begin
to ask well okay I understand as a woman
in tech for example this this and this
happens what can I do the help and there
are times when they're going to say I'm
fine I don't need the help but if you
really listen and if you take the time
to do the work they'll eventually say
you know what and the past few meanings
I didn't feel comfortable talking about
something because of you know I didn't
know if it was going to be received very
well maybe if that happens again can you
just kind of turn and say hey I like to
hear what you know I have to say and so
I found that by listening and then by
asking that to be a very effective way
to be a better a better person who can
lend privilege and technology and you
know I understand the trepidation that
some women feel about Miller allies and
an ally is a loaded term I'm going to go
into that in a little bit because to be
honest you know horrible things
sometimes are done by men to women in
tech and those are things like
microaggressions are there times when
women don't get promoted and they see
their male peers being promoted and they
aren't and there are times when women
have gone through that main I think that
men are going to be allies and you have
to
that you have to just say you know what
I'm here to listen I'm here to act in
whatever way you think is appropriate
and I think that that's one way to act
is to listen and then ask and then act
and being an ally mission being an ally
can be a loaded term and you know we
have to be honest with ourselves
whenever I say that I'm a male a lie I
have to be honest and I live in a
culture that is really anti a lie we
live in a world that regularly
reinforces misogyny sexism racism often
in very subtle ways and to think that
that doesn't have an impact on us is
really being naive we have to understand
that by living in this world that we
have all this noise of inequality and
while I believe in a total equality of
the sexes and I try to fight to help
women get into tech and be successful
make sure they get equal pay for equal
work make sure that they could promote
it when they should I have a
subconscious and I understand that
that's self conscious often it's fed
garbage by the real world and so you're
always going to be an imperfect a lie
you're always going to be someone who is
an outline in progress and we have to
understand that and by doing that you're
in Paris to say oh wow you know I still
have those really dim views of women
that I thought that I took care of and
let me think about that let me really
ponder that let me see how I can remove
this way of thinking from myself so by
realizing the struggle of being an ally
you ever to confront it head-on and you
can then continue become a better Ally
and I always tell people that being an
ally is not a marathon it's a sprint you
have to take the time I'm sorry started
sprint it's a marathon instead they're
backwards I had someone caught that yeah
that'd mean that yeah it's not a sprint
it's a marathon you know it's going to
take time to do the journey of
understanding what we can do to be the
become better allies and so just like
our software won't be bug free overnight
and our industry won't be inclusive
overnight
by working together by chipping away at
the problem I think that we can all make
a better technology industry and maybe
one day it will be the meritocracy that
we want it to be now I know that some of
you may remain unconvinced you may say
you know what I just want to write code
do you know when i'm in my you know I
got my tool set up and I got my
compilers running and I know how to get
code into production this diversity
inclusion stuff that's nice and hippie
but not really something that I think
that I should care about and I
understand that thought but I would
imagine that when Leonard Nimoy walked
into the offices of paramount to talk
about Nichelle Nichols getting equal pay
I don't have any proof of this but I'm
sure that a couple of the executives
thought you know what does paying a
black woman have anything to do with
making a sci-fi TV show and I would hope
that if Leonard Nimoy was posed that
question that he would say it has
everything to do with making a sci-fi TV
show because Nimoy played a character
that symbolized the power of infinite
diversity in infinite combinations and I
would hope that he would think that by
creating an industry where everyone
feels welcome that they'll be equally
paid they'll be equally rewarded they'll
be equally respected that that's worth
fighting for and I think that if we want
to see our industry become more
inclusive if we want to see women LGBTQA
people people of color coming to the
industry get promoted if we want that
babbling bazaar where no bug is deep
then I think that we can all have a role
to play by debugging diversity thank
and i think i have about seven minutes
for Q&A so shoot yes at the back
right
yeah so I think the question is often
there are you know women's networking
groups and companies or there's livan
groups for black people and what can we
do to to give the example of a women's
networking group may be bringing men
into that group so I have a couple of
responses to that one I totally get the
need to have safe places where you can
go to people who share your struggles in
tech I've been a member of different
groups for blacks in technology there's
a black and Technology event actually
later today and so you want to have that
safe space where you feel comfortable
either as a person of color or in LGBTQA
communities are as women where you can
kind of let your guard down a little bit
and really i'll be honest in in sharing
i actually think that instead of
bringing men into a women's networking
group it's better for men to become more
aware of what women go through and
around men talk about those those items
right so you know it's really easy for a
man when a woman is in the room to talk
about you know inclusion and how the
industry is misogynistic and all that
but what happens when you're with your
boys and you're talking about work and
so it makes a rude comment about a woman
do you correct that that's really what's
more important i think this when people
who have privilege are in a room with
people who also have that privilege
let's have the conversation out the
people when they're not in the room
misha talk about you know what how are
we paying women at our company right had
that conversation and call people to the
carpet and these are hard conversations
that have but i think that that's what
the power is when men are with men that
conversations had about what can we do
with the experience of women at our
company maybe the company is great maybe
the conversation is everything's well
but that of course requires meant to be
aware to have those traces on that I
talked about to be able to be aware of
what's happening and I and I encourage
men at my company to think about you
know how their women at our company
acting they did that kind of touch
okay thank you for the question let's
see with the blue hoodie on I think our
shirt yes what's your name what's your
name let's shot a high right tent the
years of star trek by the way this year
it's 50 years of Star Trek yeah yeah has
everyone heard of Model View culture
it's a publication if you heard of it
right raise your hand it's a great
magazine I think that becoming aware is
is reading doing your homework I highly
recommend everyone subscribing to one of
your culture it's a really important
publication few months ago Model View
culture did a study on being an ally and
being an advocate for these topics in
tekken improving the culture of tech in
the study was based on a survey and the
results were obvious it's exhausting
doing this work you know often people
who are marginalized by the system had
to stick the system that they didn't
create and the burden of doing that is
it's tough because often it's like
you're being asked to clean up a mess
that that that you didn't make and I
think that you know in my own personal
work you know I'm very active on Twitter
I gave a version of this talk call
ending privilege I github universe a few
days ago and so I'm actively talking on
twitter about my talk and how I think
it's important that that we have allies
and that we try to make the technology
industry more inclusive I know if I ever
want to find a job there's some hiring
managers that may think I this guy's a
revolutionary we don't want him to be in
our companies and so they're probably
jobs that may have been passed over for
because I'm an advocate for making
technology
a better industry I probably would want
to work for those companies anyway but
but there but there is a price to be
paid by being an ally I think it's worth
it technology is an industry that I love
I love tech I always have and if I can
find some way to make especially for you
know black women and women overall but I
know that being a double minority you're
almost done you know Dudley taxed I
think it's worth it I think that there
are benefits to leveling the playing
field I really do believe and I can
share studies with Eric with anyone who
wants to monster you can at me on
Twitter go to my last slide and I will
be happy to provide links but there
there's ample evidence that inclusive
teams are more innovative teams that
there's this that there are business
benefits of being diverse and inclusive
and so I think that fights worth it okay
Thank You l'shana I think I have time
for one more question let's see let's go
to the woman 2 on the on the end
yeah so I let me make sure I understand
your question you're saying how do you
reach out to other representing groups
and want to help them but without
putting the burden of the help are
fixing it on those groups yeah it's it's
hard because you know I often advocate
like I said for women to speak at a
kibbutz I think speaking at tikov it's
like this is really it's really great
helps you be seen as an expert makes you
more visible if you ever go for a job
interview having a recording of you
talking about the job you're being
interviewed and like the task that that
job is asking for it's really powerful I
also think that you know Sally Ride the
astronaut said that you can't be what
you can't see and by having women on
stage at tech events I would hope that
women walking by maybe young teenage
girls can say oh wait a minute there's
women at this tech conference maybe
maybe I can be intact right because I
think often there's that thought that
you know tech is a very much a
male-dominated field and only men should
be in and then you know I that that's
unfortunate but I also know that by
being on stage you are taking on the
bird and a fixing the problem and I
think that all that I can do is try to
create a more understanding industry so
that that birding is a little bit
lighter so that's why I give talks like
this that's why I do what I do that's
why I hope that people respond to our
they subscribe to Mountain View culture
and there are less than great people who
are doing work to be more this project
inclusion project include which are two
separate projects there's work being
done to make the burden lighter so that
as we get people into this movement we
all have a little bit less work to do
all right thank you so much i'll be
around feel free to come up afterwards
and i'm happy to talk with you thank you